well Academy Award nominee Greg Kinnear
is known for portraying real people on
the big screen he's played former
Philadelphia Eagles coach Dick Vermeil
and President John F Kennedy will now
he's taking on the role of California
Innocence Project attorney Justin Brooks
and the new movie Brian banks the film
is based on the true story of a teenage
NFL prospect who was convicted of a
crime he did not commit after spending
five years in prison and more time on
parole Brian banks sought out Justin
Brooks to prove his innocence mr. Bruce
I'm Ron banks oh hey Brian yeah you're
the football player right you got my
letter I got your letters plural right
look Brian I know Allison explained to
you we only work with wrongly imprisoned
people I was wrong I know I know but
you're out now okay it's a good thing
and you took a plea I don't have to
explain it's okay it's okay ninety-seven
percent of all cases plead out but you
didn't go to trial so you can't appeal
there's nothing you can do there's
always something you can do and Greg
Kinnear joins us at the table good
morning a long way from your days that
talk soon yeah but you know Brian banks
was actually at this table not too long
ago explaining his story this was six
seven years ago but it's a true story
it's an important story especially when
you consider just the timing that were
and we just talked about some Toya Brown
who was released from prison today but
you did some heavy research in terms of
really getting to know that character
you said in on some of those law law
classes from Justin Brooks at the cap at
California Western why was that so
important and what more did you do to
prepare for this role well you know
Justin in addition to starting the
California Innocence Project which has
exonerated over 30 people you know some
people have been locked up for 10 20 30
years he's also a tenured professor he's
a law student so you know
just wanted a course to hang out and see
how he does this thing and of course I
was the stupidest guy in class that day
but you know getting to follow him
around and see him and and see him do
his thing and learn about what CIP was
was obviously imperative and you know
it's amazing I mean usually when you
make a movie you don't always have the
real-life person you know those Marvel
guys don't can't look to Captain
animated you know what so so we were
lucky in that way to have both Brian
banks and Justin Brooks there as as
great assets you know telling us exactly
how these moments happened in what was a
really fantastic story there are
actually executive producers of the film
right yeah the whole time yeah pretty
much
I mean and it was you know obviously for
me meeting you know when you read the
story I mean Brian's journey he starts
at 16 years old wrongly convicted he
gets pulled into that criminal justice
system spent six years in prison and and
really it was his own advocacy Brian
yeah hold the CIP with him through this
story into getting this case overturned
with not a lot of time left and it was a
little unusual the case in the sense
that normally you know the CIP gets
people are locked up out of prison
Brian was out he was out he was on
parole but they were hesitant to even
take this that's right it's already on
parole that's right but he made the case
I'm still in jail right you know I he
still couldn't pursue his dreams as a as
a football player he still couldn't go
near a field this is a registered sex
offender so you know there were a lot of
things working against him and and the
story you know even if it weren't a true
story plays like a hell of a movie the
fact that all of this was real the fact
that these people these kind of amazing
and inspiring people were surrounding
the story was a real Justin Brooks give
you advice and how to argue a case just
to give me a few acting tips ya know he
was he was a great asset and and and
obviously somebody I you know it's
impossible not to admire a guy like this
you know made this his life's work he's
never taken a dime
from for this organization and and
they've done a lot of great work like
this from the get-go and the fact that
you know these two stories aligned you
know right at this moment was was what
made a hell of a movie when you play a
role like this and you attach to him in
some way has that changed you in any way
and how you approach some of the issues
that are out there have you gotten more
actively involved in some social justice
issues or anything along those lines
well it's impossible not to be deeply
affected you know I think watching
listen I think anybody who sees the
movie you know and I and I'm hesitant to
say that because when people say oh well
if you're gonna be you know it's gonna
give you all sorts of civics lessons I'm
like just give me a great movie which I
think this film is what in addition to
that just following the truth of the
story I don't think there's a way in
which you can't feel a passion for for
trying to you know get involved in that
you know criminal justice reform and
trying to really look at what you can do
to try to play a part in a system that
is at least when you look at Brian's
case in having need of some examination
that's broken yes yeah really getting
insight into a serious matter and people
being believed now not just with a
me-too movement but even in cases like
this yeah thank you very much Greg
Kinnear thank you Brian banks is in
theaters Friday